how's it feel knowing you've been in so
many people's bedroom you are probably
number one on the baby-making music just
to be a part of somebody's soundtrack of
your life whose main voices are their
thumbnail is your face 77 million views
the high note that's Darnell Darnell
yours me I get the chills every single
one of my kids are sponsored by you yes
American Idol would always call us and
let us know that our song was like the
number one most performed song audition
wise man we made it dude it's a grace ha
ha ha love songs RnB 90s man they're
emotional like you feel them when you
listen to it SWV is still H Talent
reconsider Jota singing boys a man ahead
of us like new addition is because it
was kids when they came out it feel like
we gotta be up in there too though are
you kidding me you guys killed it what
if you had a 10 15 year rod if we had
had a run like that I'll think we like
it definitely be a different
conversation because we were just going
to hitting our stride
Darnell let's hear your voice man right
here in my bones without you something
there did you ever think you would make
it take sweet victory I know this life
yeah why would you fit on Goliath but we
got that a value taemin given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can't no value the haters run homie
look what I become
[Music]
so every once in a while I might guests
on Value table where a lot of people say
Pat that's not entrepreneurship that's
not business that's not bodybuilding
that's not even the mob that's not even
anything why are you bringing these guys
but it's because my passion today
in my eyes I am bringing the song the
legendary song that came out if I ever
fall in love again or maybe I'm Yours or
comforter or this is where you belong
you know the place where you belong shy
they're here with me today an
interesting stat to give you guys if you
don't know about the full-time out here
today Darnell Van Rensselaer and
Garfield bright here's what you need to
know about when they came up I think it
was a 92 and they hit the Billboard Top
100 their song was number 2 for 8 weeks
straight
the only other song that was number 2
for 8 weeks straight I think was Maya L
foreigner foreigner was number 2 for 8
weeks straight they had the one song by
foreigner one of the songs that was 8
weeks straight and the number one song
at that time just so everybody knows was
by who by Whitney Houston Whitney
Houston song what which one was it it
was I will always love buddy go but the
soundtrack from the movie right the
buddy listen if you're going to be
number 2 20 buddy
it's the great Whitney gentlemen thank
you so much for being a guest on value
tainment thanks for having a good life
when you could that David that's the
fact that you gave them back but look
you know I have a scientific question
for you guys before we had any serious
stuff I'm gonna ask a very very serious
question from you guys just to kind of
see how you answer this you know uh uh
it was a heavy-duty study done by
Harvard University and I was looking at
I thought it had a lot to do with you
guys and I want to know your take on
this it was a study done in the mid 90s
okay my Harvard University very very
extensive you know study done that said
that said this song if I ever fall in
love again contributed to increase in a
population by 6.8 million people how
much how much facts is there behind that
researcher did I just make it up listen
hustle no inner house of
knowing you've been in so many people's
bedroom you are probably number one on
the baby-making music house I feel known
you have one of those songs that you
it's something that you never like it's
surreal at all times just to be a part
of somebody's soundtrack of their life
they're coming of age development and
they know you and your face and they
have an emotional attachment to you and
you don't even know the people you know
so you know and when we go perform in
front of people that everything is
edified and me you just can never get
used to something like that it's just
bigger than you but it's like American
Idol would always call us and let us
know that our song was like the number
one most performed song audition wise
within and stuff like yeah after year
after year it's incredible man and
became a classic song and we just you
know thank God we knew a part of
something like that yeah yes so let me
ask you for you guys you know the other
day I was watching
remember when Eddie Murphy came back on
SNL and he was performing this was like
a a few months ago is it - three months
ago when he came back six months ago he
came back and I was watching him and he
looked a little awkward I don't know if
you guys saw that or not if you haven't
seen it you gotta go watch it I got him
sick about a same old Eddie Murphy I
watch I'm like I don't know Paul I'm
just not feeling it I just don't think
it's the same Eddie and then I watch
Martin Lawrence you know Martin Lawrence
act and I'm watching some of his stuff I
said to myself the movie that just came
out but part three bad boys 3 yeah yeah
and i watch him Martin I'm like you know
what I also don't feel that it's the
same ol Martin the way he acts and if
for me there was a song I used to listen
to my MC Lyte remember MC Lyte keep on
keep here nod from Sunset Park
remember MC Lyte she was it was it baby
first of all let's establish we hear pop
a Negro can go in the air are you gonna
teach me on the student's name
so so but but the question I wanted to
ask you guys is when I watch Murphy and
I watch Martin and I see case you know
MC Lyte is as life changes you know
Eddie Murphy's jokes to him maybe in the
80s to him in the 2020s like kids grank
it's kind of like well you know I made
some of these so you know things I said
or some of these guys do you are you
guys evolved in a point where you're
like well you know the RMV love making
all this kind of music that we made are
you uncomfortable with that are you very
comfortable with the art that you
produce because sometimes I see the
artist changing and the fan defend is
kind of connected to the 1992 artist
writing process that as the artist man
we were so fortunate that as young guys
we had the opportunity to go to Howard
University and you know there were adult
situations that we found ourselves in in
a controlled environment like that that
allowed us to come of age but kind of
kind of like look at it metacognitively
understanding how we thought about what
we thought and that allowed us to be
writers with a different kind of
conscious like as a fashion designer you
always you know or people who do
anything you want to make it timeless if
you can you don't want to don't want to
be caught up in a fad aspect of things
and if your thing can be streamlined
enough in essential enough it can
transcend the time medicine and because
of that we we talking about having your
best friend become your lady make sure
that your lady is a friend and that kind
of a theme is not anything overtly
sexual or or anything that's trendy that
as young man we can express that with no
problem but that's 50 year old man
that's kind of like uh know we can
always talk about before love I love I
love you you have no idea how much I
love hearing because that art to me when
you listen to our me like guys come into
the end or like Pat you know how much in
the army today do you follow and I know
this may you guys probably follow it I
have a zero interest in today's art when
I tell you ski roll I tell you I have
zero interest in today's RMB or even
some of the hip hop I'm more hip hop
from the Tupac days the Biggie days the
even andre 3000 outcast on those guys
I like NAS I like those guys that I
can't do with today because I think what
you guys are doing I'm not saying I'm
not taking anything away from the guys
today but love love songs RMB 90s are
very different man they're emotional
like you feel them when you listen to it
you know do you guys still listen to
your own songs I know you're performing
all the time but do you listen to your
cell phones are kind of weird to listen
to yourself you know we got a lot of
stuff actually that Unicode didn't get
to the radio stuff that you know we like
some of our demo stuff some of our
b-side stuff so we still listen to our
cell for some of our contemporaries
jealousy and SWV is silk and yeah h-town
my friends and I'm down here Houston now
I'm hanging out with those brothers and
actually get a song together that's
hopefully gonna come out soon let me
tell you that one song good nothing body
rock and knockin that's all men that was
something else when it came out they had
they had good things going on so so
happy when you were coming up when it
first hit when when if I ever fall I I'm
gonna get to the other ones as well but
when if I ever fall in love again when
you performed it and it went out when
did you don't like guys this is it like
this has taken off when did you know
like the audience fully received that
song man we it was kind of an instant
thing it was just one of those things in
life that feedback was instantaneous
because the nature of radio back then
was phone call driven in terms of how
playlists were selected now you have the
big corporate entities dictating what
you know is played with a little will
wiggle room for the program directly to
flex their personal taste but back then
you could call in and request your
favorite song and so of course reacted
like about 30 different people
requesting it but it picked the head
legs of his own and when it started
getting played in regular rotation on
ap1 which is the larger radio stations
from which other radio outlets copied
their playlist we kind of had an inkling
that hey without a record label we're
getting radio airplay and because of
that radio airplay because of the nature
of the stations
we're charting now without being Sun and
so nobody's have you hit it big anything
but just those those those so those
earmarks those different you know read
the things that look at those those
those pieces allowed us to see what it
could be and when we got signed we kind
of knew based on that energy that we
were probably gonna get well rotated
well played and that's what happened we
crossed over without trying to cross
over because of the nature of the song
was not a like I said it was some black
guys um it wasn't necessarily pop it was
just a heartfelt song that people could
relate to and it was acapella so there
was no attention of some track or
anything it was just straight from the
heart to people's ears and that batook
that being between two other songs it
allowed us to be embossed in that
rotation so we kind of knew and then you
know our label centers overseas as soon
as we got signed so we didn't get to
feel the energy of America just [ __ ] and
we hadn't had a video so wasn't until we
came back to United States after our
promotional tools overseas when we came
back we came straight to New York the
epicenter of this trend setting in
America at that time and they embraced
us and you know New York crowd is you
know if you could if people in New York
embrace you you you've broken your own
record pretty much and that's what
happened we came back to New York we did
a show in a mall for crying out loud but
the mall was so huge I mean we thought
it was cheap it we still thought we were
like the Howard cared about her
performing them all but this particular
model was this incredibly huge mall that
was well attended it was like thousands
of people over hanging over the
banisters it was made like the Embassy
Suites when you had the banisters you
look over and man everybody in that
place was singing our song the energy
was just incredible and that day is when
we realize like you hope did have you
made it are we here you know you know
but later on it came to pass that um
that when I look back on it that was the
day that kind of started it off I think
and think in America for us that was
that day I know was that it was that the
same thing for you when you're thinking
back looking back at the the time where
you kind of felt like I think our song
is bigger than we thought it would be
you know it's funny because I'm up I was
a music major I played trumpet you know
what I mean so I was in a marching band
I've been
marching band in high school so I'm
really a bad guy and of course you know
getting the record deal and being on the
road and hearing our song on the radio
gave me that feeling like man you know
this song is a classic you know we've
made it but for me when I saw Florida a
man marching 100 said man we've made it
it's cool yeah that's cool because
you're in that world so for you that's
kind of like you know look at these guys
they're playing or something
how much after the song came out did
that happen well a few bands started
playing it matter of fact one of the
highlights when we first started
promoting our song back then in 92 we
did a little performance with gremlins
marching band that was called by the way
that's very big you had to buy you
classic yeah if it's playing Grambling
in southern you know big classic game so
to me personally just the arranger
family's band the size of them there
were other bands planning but I would
say about five years down the line when
he got to fam then I was like yes that's
cool yeah and and let me ask you have
you guys at that time already uh and
they say this is an innocent question
but this is what a lot of men and boys
will probably be thinking about prior to
that song coming out were you guys have
you guys already had plenty of
experiences with women partying having a
good time or did it kind of escalated 20
levels above what you had done prior to
the song well coming out of how you know
that no I understand we're in our 40s
right now when you know maybe early 50s
or 40s but to the 22 year old he's gonna
look back and want to know a little bit
of what it was like when a song took off
no just a period during that time you
know arguably the golden era of the
Renaissance of the R&B group and the hip
hop golden era period those two overlap
and there was a lot of you know sexual
energy because of you know people the
youth culture
produced artists that were the first
wave of kind of like icons in the new
youth culture and that was kind of like
looked at as you know sexy for a lot of
women and stuff like that and so for
sure like all the artists pretty much
you know in that day and age you know
just like the athletes and stuff but
there was no proverbial groupies or
things of that nature but it really boil
down to just I think people in that
moment understood the dynamic nature of
the type of music that we were doing the
fact that each group wasn't one of one
like Shia was not Jodeci Jody Seay was
not silk boys and men was not you know
mint-condition
and then everybody had quality music
that we all enjoy SWE like when we are
first to was the bow as a super person
yeah there were groupies in hotel
lobbies but the highlights of those
tours where when I got to performing we
get to stand on the side of stage and
watch SWV perform at their being perform
at their band like I peers we were fans
of our peers and they were also the
backdrop to our coming-of-age we
literally grew up together we were all
like 20 21 years old I'm so cool so
Campina yeah so it was like I mean to
have beef with each other and stuff like
that it was like like I too was broke
now an AC on picked me up you know
SWV picked us up a couple of times when
our tool belt broke down and I saw
something Jodeci was talking a little
smack in one of the videos I'm like I
saw Jodeci saying some stuff look at
these guys you know they got a tall guy
like this guy I don't know if you saw
that clip you know that competition but
reconsidered Jodeci and boys and men
like ahead of us like before we even got
our deal
actually in the mirror singing Jodeci
songs and boys do me a song you know me
and Darnell I was I was playing the role
of Casey
darn it was doing that sweet Jojo really
a lot of respect for those guys even
though you know I've known about the
interview and stuff like that but you
know we were young oh that kind of stuff
and everything you know I'm sure well I
would hope they don't harbor those
feelings but they're highly bounded
myself and Casey and Jojo and out of
enough you know I don't know how Devon
takes pills but I got respect for him
he's a leader like me and a boy is bad
musically and stuff like that but you're
yourself you're a Libra
I'm October the 12th yeah yeah I'm gonna
talk we're six days apartment I'm
October 18th my mom was a 60 that's
crazy
yes people are libras I don't have yet
to ask you some things in the world are
libras this is proven now I know it's
know it you what ones your birthday
Darnell let's see when your birthday's
Doris this family so April what may 17th
on May 17 Taurus is running so he's a
Taurus yeah remember see what a
dedication day he know so Tauruses are
extremely stubborn man when you guys you
know we very interesting you a community
of people are tourists and his
stubbornness helped us out a whole you
need not abuse Knox you need that in
business 100% that in business it's very
effective for somebody on the team to be
stubbornly determined to get something
done it's very hard to write
yeah because libras have a different
personality and tourists have a very
different personality very interesting
right there so so when you guys were
going back and you think about you know
you brought up the band's Joe to see all
these other guys and you're listening to
them was that almost like a playbook at
that time on how to pick up and put a
band together or what was the if you
were to say the this is how typically
bands were started or groups were
started together what what is what is
the commonality amongst different groups
that got started whether it's yourself
Jodeci black street voice two men you
name any of those guys is there a
certain set of formula or everybody has
a different story
yeah I think I mean we had a different
story for sure but I think you know you
get around guys who are like-minded
musically or you know we bounce off each
other well riding in music wise and then
performance wise and then you kind of
feel it start building in a harmony and
yeah I'm sure like that's that's how it
was for us so I'm sure the other guys
there was a similar kind of you know
Union and feeling each other out and
realizing they live well together
creatively and such to the point where
they felt like a we we got something
that we could share with the world
you know I mean and that's how we felt
back then it seemed to me when I look at
it a lot of the groups were organically
but he came to get organically with
exception maybe like I involve who kind
of got they want contests individually
I put together by foster Muslim means
name Foster like Michael or something
like but um us shy few like it looks
like silk
Jodeci is two sets of brothers that grew
up in the church culture together knew
about each other all of us our age town
all of us kind of organically you know
uh I was in May came from the performing
arts school you know they they all knew
each other and that one those ways and
they organically grew up together and
Michael Bivins kind of put them on and
stuff like that so there is a
commonality in terms of deep tissue
connectivity between the groups and I
know that that affects the sound and
everything
typically except for like an invoke just
came out sounding ridiculously
incredible without having grown up
together and stuff like that but the
rest of us I do Darnell we made in
Howard he was my roommate freshman year
I was the first guy I knew you know me
and Darnell yeah 17 years old at our
university they won that was my guy so
you know that took a life of his own his
dad was already the manager of a good
car riff and he was a guidance counselor
at the Esau high school with Joe Clark
and all that with our know excellent so
he has songs before they came out that
we were singing to the girl dorms and
stuff like that so we kind of
organically were basically practicing
for what was going to end up being a
singing career without us even owning at
the time you know in the chemistry
itself you know like place where you
belong you mention that song that's kind
of a showcase for me and Darnell if you
you know get down to it he does the
first verse I do the second verse and
it's a contrasting style but it is
really emotional and it worked because
we were already doing like I said I was
trying to mimic Casey of course I could
never sing like Casey when I was in the
mirror being Casey all day loved him you
know yeah just people just watch the
five heartbeats and go in the mirror and
perform songs will be boys the missiles
would be Joey but we had that chemistry
way back then and then developed and in
kohu and so what it became and we still
shot so let me let me ask you this were
you guys did you guys kind of have an
idea of saying I think one day we're
gonna be big where you guys flock in a
group telling each other and Francaise
guys one day we're gonna go one day
we're going to do this was there a
vision or is it accidental what did you
talk about the beginning portion of like
how I came okay well actually you know
the other original members three of us
are in a fraternity called Alpha Phi
Alpha we were online pledging
two of us one of the guys was our big
brother and we realized during that
process that we were into music so when
we got off line we just decided to kind
of write songs and just get around the
piano and see what comes of it Carl one
of the members that left he actually was
I guess the only one at that time that
was thinking about a career in the music
industry as a songwriter producer so he
but he wrote he didn't play he just
wrote lyrics so we kind of arranged the
music he would sing us to lyric who'd
arrange the music go to the studio
produce it and just start stockpiling
songs to possibly sell so once we
started singing around a piano working
out our songs
Garfield me and Garfield reconnecting
because from freshman year we kind of
you know started doing that a different
thing on campus we were still tight as
peas but we're into different things and
then we kind of caught back up heavy
again like the freshman year right when
we were doing this writer writer thing
with my frat brothers so he started
first just coming as my friend coming
and then when we would lead a rehearsal
or leave the writing session he was
saying back the songs to me like man I
like that one song you do and he would
sing it to me
and I'm listening to him like man this
guy can sing about something you know I
mean it's like he wasn't focused on it
so it wasn't you know as polished as it
became it was wrong but I can hear it
well so the next session I put him on
the spot I say man she could sing me
he's holding out on us you know we
started arranging our harmonies with the
four part and we heard it just started
sounding like this is right man so add
to that like you know a lot of groups
that form you know they get their feet
wet doing local shows and kind of
establish a following and that kind of
we did one show before we got a record
deal you're not an academy it was it was
in a tower in
every hostile crowd because they kind of
mimic the Apollo this particular video
it happens every year it's like a
variety show and it was chock-full of
talent who eventually got Sun a rapper
named Tracy be that Sean Alan fugu
called pure soul brother named Eric Roby
since New Jersey that could sneak his
butt off they either becoming the dope
artist well they all got booed and sold
that show was like a litmus test you
know like if you don't get food maybe
you can do something yeah we went out
singing about seven boys and man songs
in the medley and um you know started
off with at ten nine hey you know we did
that came into it real smooth so didn't
[ __ ] knock that off and when I go
away you know please don't
we're there we had them and by the end
of it man they wanted us to keep going
so we came out we didn't sing there we
had a songs and plus we ain't got food
it I was ready to cut my losses in be
sung if I ever that night for the first
time in front of you now how many people
are there by the way just to kind of
give us perspective how many people can
crimp in Cody I'm thinking least hundred
something like that it was a full
capacity whatever that thing you can
hold and the football players and your
crowd you know that a rowdy ones they're
gonna be everybody just have fun our
experience they didn't boo us and by the
time the chorus came around the second
time the whole crowd was singing if I
ever fall in love like they knew it like
it was a song that was out already so we
went from not getting boom you know
thinking God for DEXA like on the stage
immediately after the new encore when we
got that energy from that crowd on the
curves close we stood there on that
square on that stage and say yo yeah I
wanna try to get a record deal just like
that no like I'm here and we will say
yeah and so we just went for it and
about a week later we were at the
avenues of America New York trying to
stop at all the different labels you
know sing for them and stuff like that
that was an interesting experience no no
nobody got it you know because they
thought that the acapella song wouldn't
and it wasn't original I rewrote it
wasn't like happily me remade exactly
unknown entity would have passed I'm not
sure program directors nah you know it
just did his own thing indie scene
rest was history on out so do that ah
would you add anything to that yeah it
was so to your question and it was it
was pretty I would say accidental but it
was definitely organic in you know
that's going to be like stars lined up
that is right now at that time when you
guys are doing that who is the god of
R&B at that time is it boy stur man at
that time and Jodeci or who who were the
main names that they were becoming that
like for us before we got a deal they
were looking at like I say he was
cultured on the hip-hop styles was on
and poppin but the army side was kind of
like really really coming of age and
started with it like boys the minute he
started you know but those were the guys
are kind of like in the new age started
jumping out in front of everybody Jota
seeing boys the man had that and
everybody can find themselves in either
the clean-cut crooners of the boys
demand or the sexual kind of like vibe
of Jodeci between those two you had
everything you needed musically for
whatever situation and so you know those
guys too bad but you were saying go
ahead so you were saying that the
benefit you had back then is the guys on
radio could just call in and say I want
to request shy if I ever fall in love
again so it was kind of controlled by
the audience where today it's more
controlled by the big corporations on
who they want to put up and who they
like right it's not necessarily all the
audience maybe today than before
although some may say today because of
social media you kind of have the
equalizer because you can see who on
social media is taking off I was jukebox
a big play of yours or no cuz it was was
that another cuz remember back in the
days you'd be sitting there like man I
hope somebody goes and gets the Janet
Jackson anytime anyplace I want to see
that one more time you know just but Sir
mix-a-lot whatever one up sir mix-a-lot
songs or you would say just put if I
ever fall in love again you know cuz you
had that going on did that kind of help
you guys out as well or not really it
was just another additional you know
element of your game oh yeah video Juba
x bt MTV
all of those where again it was love oh
yeah that helped in radio like I said
you know radio like a lot of like like
Jody for instance at first they they
weren't like a crossover group because
it was so urban even though everybody in
the urban community loved Jodeci but we
were a group that was allowed to cross
over and still have an urban base so in
terms of like the people who we were
exposed to in the taste that were me
they kind of threw us chained like you
know acclimated to what that new R&B
stuff was gonna be and then they found
other groups in that way you know boys a
minute paved that way for us but you
know it was like so what what happened
what happened with the band cuz I know
when I look it up I see a you you guys
are original you're from the original
there's four of you you said you
mentioned Carl earlier and there's also
Mark J I believe right that means three
of you were part of the you said three
of us were part of the stern eternity
you were so what what happened because
almost every single time these bands
come together and they're killing it
some events happen when there's a
falling out what happened to your bed
because you guys for like six years you
were on fire well like I was saying
earlier from the beginning Carl had
aspirations on being a songwriter
producer so after that first album you
know he ended up getting a lot of
credits you know for producing and
writing um so he I guess wanted to
parlay that into you know a solo career
songwriter producer ASAP so almost kind
of like that we got a second album a
second I'm modeling was good you know he
he was ready to go from the gate really
ya know from the game yeah like he said
he came into it like I'm a writer
producer my first you know stamp on the
industry happens to be my group to show
you what I do but immediately I'm ready
to go out and produce and write for
other people like from the gate God so
and then also
- it was some internal stuff with the
label we happen to come at a time where
you know right after our first album I
think they got bought out by Seagram's
Edgar Bronfman bought out MCA yeah that
whole staff all the field reps all the
radio reps all of the artists
development all the people that worked
our first album a lot of them just got
fired they brought in new staff and so
by the time my second album came you
know new people would have a new agenda
they probably brought some artists with
them you know so mean that turned over
again like a fire they're doing our
project it was maybe like two or three
turn over doing it so it's short just
the business the business of it you know
what I mean
some people can navigate the business
and their interests are alike in the
line to where they can still keep moving
collectively yeah sometimes it gets to
you know I mean Corrections and that
what's mark up to so what it because I
couldn't find anything on caught on Carl
or mark today like when I search names
on on Google or YouTube were interviews
I didn't see nothing would call Martin
and I couldn't find anything with but I
found a lot with shy with the two of you
what happened to them what do they do
afterwards well mark you know mark it's
funny because mark is now married to the
young lady who was in our video that we
did at our university baby I'm yours a
fortuitous leap back up in life like and
got married like the leading lady of the
van is crazy but I know market going to
real estate of course is I think he got
his license you know he was a zoology
major Howard he got his degree
you know that was one of the if he
things we didn't know if Marcus don't
come being a group or if he was gonna
graduate first and stuff like that that
was a big deal for him back you know I
think this the real estate thing is what
he kind of like primarily attached
himself to and I'm sure he's still doing
some like big music somewhere because he
was talented you can't just not do that
if you've been doing it play and what is
Carl doing today like
since then do you guys know what Carl's
donor no no not the last I think he was
some kind of check typos he has some
kind of tech job or some kind of tech
worker he does IT type of stuff you know
I might be I'm definitely paraphrasing
and lumping it and you know rounding it
off but I think he has something to do
with that you know you know and I'm sure
he still has a niche for music and stuff
like that because he could really write
and that kind of thing so you know but
we haven't really kept tabs on Carl like
me at all I don't I don't keep up with
mark you know like he had his baby a
couple years back I got him his baby got
his first Timberland skullcap and his
first Timberland shoes for me you know
but um but yeah you know like I said
they're they're the things in life that
kind of like you know you see sort of
movie fire heartbeats you know life is
not life can be asymmetrical the way
people grow it's never you know and how
you handle that and deal with that and
recognize that in a moment dictates
where it ends up but that guy over there
and I we we were like I guess like true
brothers that you know might have even
transcended the fraternal thing that he
had with the other guys
we were just cut from the same cloth
both from urban type of environments
growing up in high school both hip-hop
more hip-hop hair kind of brothers our
experiences were like similar and we
were like forged in fire together by
being roommates and going through the
coming-of-age stuff together then we get
it to this platinum group and still keep
the one together and now we 15 still you
know connect it at the hip so that
that's something that we're blessed to
be a part of that that's a again
everybody has a different story but I'm
always curious to know what happens when
when you go back to the song if I ever
fall in love who's whose main voices are
there dead words I know your face like
if I go on YouTube right now and I type
in a fight or fall in love the thumbnail
is your face you're on there is 77
million views I mean but when you listen
to it whose voice is which one I'm
curious because I can't figure that when
I'm watching it Carl's on the first
verse and then Darnell is the guy doing
the chorus that no one else pretty voice
to need the high note that's Darnell and
then
that's me and then um you know and it
you know that's that's how it flowed and
in the loose harmonies few because it's
tough everybody but typically shod when
when we did songs unless it was a song
that one person brought to the table
which is rare like if I ever was one of
those together forever I think was one
that Mark had in high school he brought
to the table but usually people sit down
and look like hip-hop artist somebody
would come up with a hook and then we'll
basically pinpoint who we thought
vocally was sounding good on the song
and that person would then write his
first when you heard somebody singing
most of time they will be a part you
know I mean so I'm gonna play the
acapella because I just want to listen I
can't get time
so that that's called that's Darnell
yeah
Darnell yours
[Laughter]
oh thanks to me and I got north with
your coming up come a beer that's you
yeah good for you right here man say it
I get the chills to me it's like I'm
listening to this thing I don't know man
I think every single one of my kids are
sponsored by you guys just so you know
and by the way you know a lot of times
people what's your favorite out of all
of them by the way if you were to say
the one you like the most cuz cuz to me
it was always a close between if I ever
fall in love and comfort I know a lot of
people are now comforters not their
number one for me was very close because
comforter is a interesting song and then
you got obviously baby I'm yours right
and then the place where you belong
which was in which was a Beverly Hills
Cop 3 what would you that's it that's it
what's what's your favorite out of these
songs well it's interesting because
comforter was a song that the label did
not want to put out in fact they wanted
to prove us brash young challenge for me
in it rookies wrong based on we thought
we knew the industry in any industry and
they want to show us that now comfort
but what was happening was they were
labeled because we were being pushed
towards the big pop stations where
alienating our black music base so the
black of radio stations we weren't going
through those and doing walkthroughs and
sit downs and they were kind of getting
mad at us so we knew we had an urban
song when you do the pulse of the black
community was kind of like let us know
you know so we told the label look man
the pulse of the streets you know your
marketing department put out comforter
next and they would say don't put maybe
I'm yours out next but it was like okay
we'll show you and they let comfortable
with minimal you know money go behind it
they didn't really do the stuff that
they usually do a radio and all that and
comforters still kind of had his own
legs and went gold without any really
grill support at all it was just purely
the fans and so that also because they
couldn't say I told you so
they still put baby I'm yours after that
but I think if they hadn't took
comforter out second we would only had
two singles off that which would mean if
I haven't baby I'm Yours they would have
stopped it maybe even let us do another
album or not but we got three singles up
a deal just because they wanted to prove
us wrong with comfort which happened to
end up being one of our biggest songs
and it was in the top 10 and stuff like
that you know yeah I just want pretty
clear because for some people that may
be you know they're younger they don't
know what it is this is this is comfort
you got to hear this I mean it's just
you know it's like you would bring the
girl over to plays and you would say
look I just want you to know there's a
couple rules I have if I'm bringing it
back to my place
what's that no kids no sex nothing but
just let me play one song for us to get
in the mood Oh having to get
conversation together and you would play
this I mean by the time it's over you
broke the two rules your game is pretty
smooth oh my gosh and tell me what's on
your mind this is just something else so
for you guys you got you got a lot of
them which one of them is your favorite
I'm curious I might you can for an
artist it's tough to say which one's
their favorite but what's your because
it's like your baby what's your favorite
out of these songs me I was yeah I mean
if I ever it has a special place because
you you see the fair reaction when you
perform that you hear the stories like
you said of man that song was the first
time I met my wife or that was when we
got married too so it has a special
place there's another song we did with
jay-z called tonight and to have like
like Garfield said we're hip-hop here so
to have the legendary Marley Marl
produced that number one and
have jay-z who was a hot young artist
trailblazing at that time to get on our
track
three Version three verses right exactly
you know the main so oh I mean I'm still
kind of like mad the label didn't really
promote that like they should've but
yeah that's a gem that we just have like
a special one right that's right but
it's disjoint with the great jay-z give
you some context about that man just so
you can understand how he lays coming
through this industry like at that point
time the turnover was crazy within the
black music department and they had just
gotten these new cats Pharrell Harold
whatever is in boobs name D Harold Dave
Harold Harrison yeah so he was in there
now and you know we had a relationship
you want to do a remix to I don't want
to be alone that was like the second
singles that we had on own back face and
um we contacted our manager at the time
independently not the label I manager
contacted morning more somehow and he's
like okay I'll go remix when you guys um
I got a guy want to put on there and so
we got the track and the track was that
you know like we did prepare so nobody
beats the biz or something that we
listened to back in the day and that was
the track he was letting this rock so me
and D happen to write that and um he got
this new artist who had just come out
named Jay Z who is only song I think at
the time was a ain't no bling with Foxy
Brown and um you know he jumped on it
you know he was the face of hot 97 at
the time and Marley more blow that up
but we only paid $5,000 at the time out
of our own pocket because the label was
not trying to support this endeavor so
he scraped up my little five thousand
gave it to maro maro
he put his guy named Daisy on there
because he was a hair radio guy at high
97 he was in his interest because he was
pissed project he played the song like
ridiculous and it was number one
highlighted 8 in New York for some crazy
amount of weeks maybe eight weeks there
too you know but the label because we
paid for it not them because we sort of
him they weren't politically invested
and they didn't do a video for it now
Matthew sign
jay-z had a
hope for that song hey you didn't do a
video for I didn't want to do a video
for because at the time they were kind
of trying to like get us off the label
like we had some political stuff going
on our album was called blackface and
you know blackface harkens back to Al
Jolson and all such things but we were
trying to twist it
we had a statement and said inside of
your own face here's a blackface and
black in that way we were kind of like
was like info mystic for um pure for
good and we want to switch the
narratives coming from how a university
you know the black meaning opposite
double from taking all that kinda stuff
so that was our way of kind of giving
back in a creative way taking a stance
kind of innocuous but not and a label
kind of thing on the local issue with
that and um they put our album out
before they put a single out for
blackface and they didn't let the stores
right on the bulletin board that size
coming on November or whatever
the album was just sitting in for like a
month before a single he became now
usually the single comes off like a
month and a half
Wester appetite didn't drop the album it
was the opposite so the albums were
being sent back to the label because
nobody knew they were there did a single
came out and when the people came to
store funny to get the single it was
already shipped back and even with all
that blackface still out the gate went
gold but a lot got sent back before it
even got to sell so I'm sure that would
have been platinum - it was another way
but those are the types of things but
the morning one thing we kind of created
that and thank God because like a lot of
the DJ's now kind of mark each other you
know in terms of grain you know you got
that jay-z shy joint you know Nene
because it's kind of little collector's
item that's call yeah what is that what
is the place where you belong crank for
you I love that song that's one of the
songs that we performed that first when
we come out
it has temple to it and like I said
that's me and my brother Darnell rockin
uni but I have to give credit where it's
due
Carl and this guy named trailer is I
don't remember trailer is credible
singer um they wrote that they got
together in the song right Terry yeah
Mariah Carey and he's in other places I
hear his voice I think it was good
pricing here home tell me what you
wanted whatever that song is but yeah
you know why you need
we came back to the States Harling him
kind of went into the lab and that came
out of it must be recorder didn't put
our funk on it you know it became one of
our favorite song but at the time I
remember people that the label kind of
like not feeling it because it was so
different at that time and if I ever a
comforter it was tempo but others were
slow love type of stuff but after a
while man we had an overwhelming
response from probably because it's so
emotional you know Darnall coming up it
you know they just set the tone you walk
away from me I mean that song is just
you know I I you know it's crazy this
video didn't detail well I mean I don't
know how you guys has a song but when I
look at my 600,000 oh my god is he
opening Darnell dude it's a great yeah
that's that's a sick song I mean listen
here's what's crazy people ask me what
songs I work out to work out to the
Bible fall in love you can't but I can
work out to this I don't know why this
fires me up because this for me I can
work out to the bedroom and I can work
out that the gym it's a crossover
[Laughter]
there's something about it the beat is
also you know kind of moves use it's not
up your voice man let's hear your voice
in the give us some right here in my
without you something there
[Music]
now hey you know for some of us who
don't have a voice for some of us who
don't who don't have a voice we wonder
if those who have a voice how often
their girl says can you sing to me you
know can you can you do a lyric to me
can you do something to me how often
does that happen to you guys over the
lap you know since you've been singing
don't know Garf coffin has that happens
you can you sing a lyric from me does
that happen often
it used to they're not you know I start
asking for pay and then it oh man that's
classic that's classic so so for you
guys when you think about RMB I like
what you said
Garfield when you said you're also fan
of the game because you're coming up
with everybody
what what what were some of the songs
for you that leveled you and stopped you
I can tell you songs that'll stop me
it's three songs that stop me what were
some songs that completely leveled you
when you heard it you said oh my gosh
what is this all about
or did my favorite group is make edition
so they have a song that's not even
their main single like I liked all their
singles but they had a song called ten
million strong that thing every time I
played is like the first time i meani
and it just kicks me all in my teeth man
like Stokely Timmy is strong his little
song and then um that um song SWV had a
song I always songs were hits
but when they came up with a human
nature remix the Teddy Riley and then
when they came out with that own what's
the guy the guitar player they go what's
that God plays a guitar with that melody
there a melody that they did that um
Pastore
um jaq-jaq hope-a story that's his name
he's a guitar guy he that's his melody
to one of his things you know that song
explores me too man but this one rain by
SWV
this or no not that at this one this
shall be the Jocko past story
no the song is called rain but Jaco
Pastorius
did the music who lick that they use for
the verses came from human brain yeah
yeah I remember this we got to the moon
I don't know how about yourself songs
that stopped you you know what it's been
so many man but I'll tell you one
recently how you were speaking about how
music started changing and you felt
yourself not being able to tune in to
the news so yeah I'm driving on the
highway one day feeling you know pissed
off about the direction of music song
called lions tigers and yes yes tigers
and bears yeah as ancillary jazmine
sullivan I mean the musician was that a
harp they used I mean just to use a
harpy type of plucky harp sound and arm
be Wow
[Music]
that's ten years old by the way this is
not a new song right yeah I checked out
about ten years ago almost til she saved
me with that one what else any other
song cuz you know you you're someone
that you you know you uh you you gotta
you got a ridiculous voice yourself who
else is it for you that stopped you oh
wow I may take six yeah oh my god yes
you know when they came out I guess he
was big six I don't know Wow love and
like 886 in the harmony structures
clothing night I mean my mother is when
you do our cappella you're naked in it
you can you can import I mean to
understand like in music like when
you're when you're doing acapella you
can sometimes hide behind you know the
music or whatever instruments that are
playing it's easy to hide behind it
sometimes when you perform it but if you
do an acapella you are net you screw it
up everyone's gonna catch it made up
notation risk it's very risky and I got
pledged Patrick I got players in the
group man cuz you know out like he said
I was very wrong and I was a bystander
basically as they were rehearsing so I
was picking up you know some stuff but
when I had to enter the fray and really
do it but the notes that I was
intuitively hearing to end certain
resolve certain Corazon what was the
wrong one and I had to memorize where
they wanted me to go to fit it to the
yeah you know how hard that was to do
and then performance ready and as soon
as I'm getting a hang of it we got a
record deal and now we are Arsenio Hall
Show I'm like Jesus yeah that's cool
so all-time right now if I would ask you
greatest R&B band of all time who would
you say top five and you rank them I
know you guys talked about this because
in sports we'll say greatest baseball
player greatest football player great
you know the golden basketball is Jordan
oh it's this guy are we talking about
the 90s or you just saw Toby oops
like to me to go do all of them are in
the nine anyways let's just let's just
stick to 90s ad you know if you want to
go into 2000 is fine but 90s 2000 who
would you say top five best R&B singers
or bands you can eat if you want to go
Keith Sweat right Evan Campbell some
stuff that maybe people don't know about
you pick and choose so many groups have
some beasts into my singers vocally
wives like all the groups actually has
somebody in there that was ridiculous
like silk with below G then you had like
a course Josie with Jojo and Casey 810
Athena rest in peace with that boys may
condition with Stokely who actually the
drummer of Stokely is what he's really
his big big gift is he's a drummer parks
lungs they're you know in the cocoa like
she's like a machine you know us with
Darnell to be represented one of one so
the top five would be I mean there's got
to be a goat though I mean I couldn't in
making my order of like the old hit like
the cocaine like new addition was is our
is our uncles like in that way like you
know they kind of really start to
Renaissance cuz it was kids when they
came out of the group and they grew up
with that so you know they kind of
started that youth culture when it
whether youth culture they were kind of
like the group to gravitate yeah we grew
up with them for real all the artists in
this 90 see what we knew
as our light just like Google young Mike
and all that but so I would have to rank
them somewhere up there like you know
like they kind of like was our old hits
you know in that way you know they all
students BPD and all that and then but
then you can you know and you got a go
with like the record sales and stuff
with boys and men and Jodeci and what
they mean they gotta be up in there like
you know I feel like we gotta be up in
there too though you know I mean we
didn't have this long career and a big
body of work a lot of them got changed
to have but just creativity um and just
being like a one-of-one in a way that
was not typical and then how organically
came together may not sound was just
like it was simple but not basic I think
that that and what you are you kidding
me you guys killed it I know you then
saying oh no you know from the fan
standpoint you're like what if you guys
went seven more years
what if you guys just went five more
years not even 20 years you know it's
hard to do that long but what if you had
a 10 15 year run if we had had a run
like that I don't think we like it
definitely be a different conversation
because we were just going to hitting
our stride as young men as well as our
talents well like I was just my voice is
finally coming into it I was just
learning I was just getting the hang of
this singing thing and developing a
style you know cuz I got just thrown
into this and I was you know in
everything doing another album but as
before originals but I think that we
would definitely have some big to offer
and some more hits definitely so sure
good stuff like that but I put us in
that top five I have to represent but I
got to give props with other crews to
you know know know who do you have who
do you have that maybe yeah Garfield
didn't mention any names you have yeah
just the way he did it usually criteria
used you got to give a new addition
there's you got to give even boys demand
Josie there's because they kind of
started ours little segment of the you
know army movement male group movement
there's a group called riff that
Garfield was speaking about earlier they
were in a movie lean on me
they say I'm strong in the bathroom yeah
man for man I think they will probably
one of the best groups right in the back
yeah
remember that name is a serious yeah
they're serious they're real underrated
they think you know they came out real
early where the labels didn't really
know how to promote urban music like
that they were like one of the first I
have used his word but test them he's
like hey you know and so they got caught
up in the figuring out of it you know
what I mean and but they they're super
talented emotional man baby crazy right
unreal I'm telling you like it speaks to
your spirit may your soul it's very
interesting when it when it wouldn't a
talent can get to that and to me I think
a cappella is what it was able to do
that it's not everybody's game it's very
risky to do that and obviously this
movie's got a very special place in my
heart it's uh it's a great movie about
leadership and being able to make a
change and somebody that doesn't give up
on people you guys know about that movie
I don't need to tell you guys about that
movie but it's a powerful movie you know
that's cool Darnell you went to that
school in his dad's night is counsel and
the manager of that group Joe Clark was
not principal right at that time and
it's funny because that school song
every morning he we had the guys come in
and singing on loudspeaker that's how we
would start our date old school how
discipline was the school how how
discipline was it ran well you know what
man I mean Joe Clark got a lot of
it made for a good story and he
definitely was kind of like you know one
of the people that made it happen but
really it was like my dad was a social
worker the music teacher mr. Nelson the
guidance counselor mr. Smith yeah that
time was this man we had a lot of elders
in the community who really get down you
know what I mean so course yeah so to
the point where think about somebody at
your age with your accomplishments is
remembering how they influenced you
coming out like you mentioned how many
kids at that age give them respect for
being the men and the women that they
are today yes sometimes you sometimes
influence you put into people you know
one time one of my teachers call me my
help and guidance teacher she was
emotion she was having a rough day
she's my pen pal I'm her pen pal we
write letters to each other and she was
my helping guidance teacher 27 years ago
she says you know these students don't
do this and they're not grateful like
you guys ruin all this I said I said
miss Sinclair man just think about I
joined the army because of you know I
was a 14 year old kid with a 1.8 GPA and
you believe in this kid and you were
always respectful but you challenged the
hell out of him you were tough she was
for 11 and she never I'm six four and a
half
I mean I'm intimidating I was a
bodybuilder back then it would just come
up to me and have the respect I said you
have to realize I'm a byproduct of you
look at the impact you made on this
guy's life I said be patient I promise
you these kids are gonna come back and
they're gonna be grateful for you we did
a special event where we went back and
surprised in front of her students and
told her how much she means to me and my
family but I relate I relate on what she
may go down as just a health and
guidance teacher but not in my book
right Madonna's a hero my book on where
she know people like how to have a lot
of respect for a lot of respect for how
do you feel about the current direction
where music is going to is it's
something that interests you like this
current R&B and rap kind of a pull you
in draw you in like you did back then
you mean well it's funny because this is
interesting I look at it kind of like a
study you know I mean these kids have so
much access to information and it's such
a microwave age you know I mean they
want to give to the gratification part
quick you know what I mean
so when they're coming from their
perspective in their music that's what
it's reflecting you know what I mean
that our thing like you said a love song
sitting down listening to your elders
getting the right game for the right
woman trial and error you know all the
feelings of puppy love all that yeah
they just a couple of texts you know
mean and I mean so it's interesting it's
just a seed for me how do they approach
the internet age and the information age
and having access to you know life just
being so sped up you know I mean how do
they turn it into art and music how do
they reflect that in their art so some
of it is kind of like oh that is just
something totally different than I'm
wired to even I mean and some of it is
like that's interesting like that that's
pretty interesting you know so I won't
say bad or good is interesting that just
that gland Oh interesting
it's hard what would you say I say you
know there are definitely different a
Hawks and between each one in the same
genre you see music representing like a
two-way mirror like a byproduct of your
soul and as reflected by what society is
giving it and those two fine and happy
medium and so in this stage if you look
in a bigger picture on the macro scale
there's a lot of convoluted there's a
lot of fast twitch energy there's a lot
of different pieces and places of
information and a lot of data at one
time trying to figure out and it forces
you to see I don't need the essential
real quickly but also delegate in terms
of you might not know but you need to
know to find out who knows it so it
doesn't allow for deep-tissue kind of
interrogation of different kind of like
of craft like writing lyrics and stuff
like that it it calls for what's the
dope is hook what's the dope is way and
the quickest way I can get your
attention drag you in and then swag it
out and so as a result you see stuff
like normal rap come into existence
going right along sociologically with
you should be able to say you know what
I mean
cuz you see can understand
now we've often feel me forget the
understanding just came filming so
mumble rat just like crunk days I see
the parallels where the expression of it
is purely or soul is being but but the
way it comes across musically if you
comparing it to an older you know
version of iteration of music it looks
like it's coming on warranty just like
texting by English teachers look at
texting is like oh my god it's the worst
thing you could ever do all these
abbreviations
but the kids yeah yeah the money was a
part of it so you gotta use few
characters as possible and still convey
meaning so how do you do that and still
be effective you do what they did and so
that's genius in that but at the
iteration in the time as it's coming
from the old way looks kind of crazy
until they finds itself and now now it's
full-out accepted and now is something
that's a thing but so I think we're
gonna growing pain growing stages of
something to find in itself to where it
can be like a stable spot or whatever
the ocean of craziness around us is
nothing very well very well put for
somebody like me because you know the
way you described it I've made a lot of
sense on how things have evolved the
music now let me ask you this if
somebody is watching this and that
they're diehard fans of yours and what
you guys did in the 90s and they're a
band they're going to Morehouse I don't
know you know because first of all you
guys went to Howard Howard's isn't
Howard the number one University for
mecca isn't it isn't it number one
university african-american leaders come
you know what that's then I think you
have what are the schools again correct
me if I'm wrong it's Howard I think is
it's a Hampton Morehouse I missing one
other one the spell yeah Clark in
Atlanta like the whole a you see I mean
any one of those any one of those you go
to they breathe leaders is what they've
done a great job reading leaders but if
the kids watching this two three friends
four friends they have similar stories
they kind of want to come up in the rme
world today how different is it today
versus your tonic
well like you were saying social media
on the business side of it it allows you
to if you want to put the work in fine
you know the fan base that you want for
what you do you know what I mean
also I don't know I mean I'm not in it
obviously so like I was saying having
life so sped up you know to where you
don't really get the chance like we did
to experience the journey of things you
know what I mean the trial and error
yeah I really can't speak to any you
know I can't speak to how they're
dealing with being in a more spread up
type of you know you know where life so
I would just say just be as creative as
you can you know and what you do well I
had to definitely make sure the product
is good like I heard of comedians
interview the other day and they were
asking a similar question he was like a
man just just be funny right so for me
make good music make music that
officially reflects who you actually are
so you can stand the test of time and as
you involve that essential part of
yourself that was expressed musically
won't fade too much because if it's you
it's really you and the uniqueness of
today's artists to go directly to the
marketplace without having to deal with
a label and the oversight because it's
my dissertation I look at how black
males navigated spaces in the inevitable
power space looking at diagonals and
classrooms and black males my label and
on the label one of the lessons that
we've learned dealing with their power
is that once we are artists once we
produce a art piece as soon as it's
burst it becomes product it's no longer
art for us and as product as part of the
business side immediately and so to
understand that yet Joe art is gonna be
a product for somebody else to actually
cut the check that have the oversight in
all of different processes if you can
control all that within yourself you can
put out a true expression of yourself
and the people who resonate to that will
resonate to that because it can be
consistently given by you to them and
you might not be famous but you have a
core audience that won't waver and you
come in if you can maneuver that you can
grow that as you could nurture that and
you'll control that so the only identity
is key at the end of the data is the
product you make a very good point if
you have a good product people gonna pay
for it whether it's a Chappelle it's a
hard it's a bill Byrd Seinfeld or it's a
it's in Jodeci it's an usher it's a SW
it doesn't matter if you got a good
product they're gonna pay for that and
eventually someone's going to take
notice of you guys this is the last part
of the interview I'll give you a name of
a challenge and you take me to tell me
one word that comes to mind okay one
word that comes to mind I'll give you a
name you tell me one word that comes to
mind uh sure
talented youngster soul food dancer good
kid good mama you said one word I will
say star just Justin Bieber who would
you say Justin Bieber speechless is a
good word yeah there you go
he's iconic enigma I don't like two
words I don't know he just rinse it out
that's a cool man that's cool because
sometimes he gets hate out more families
that we're we're fans of Bieber it's
interesting seeing your take on that
Jonas Jonasson legendary legendary voice
come in polished Amish big leagues ooh
addition teachers legendary here legit
Europe a planet our I'm curious Atlantic
spoke I listen to Atlantic Star special
special yeah Jackson five the greatest
heart dwellers Marvin Gaye super classic
yeah
blacks down with it black stream Black's
Peters family family you know I probably
listen to black streets don't leave me
girl I don't know I had it on replay
when I
I can tell you what month that song came
out because I joined the army when that
month this all came out I'm listening to
repeat
how about 112 I think we never before
they got a deal they came to us and song
if I ever - it's like you know see we
can put them on whatever and blew me
away and that was before I even heard
Slim's voice I hacked it was a 20 that
other digital news but um so for all I
know you know a lot of guys like love me
or Cupid or they like the peaches and
cream I was about it's over and I don't
know if you remember it's over now what
is this numbers in your pocket that's
cool song okay h-town h-town somebody
back and be southern soul man just
southern so sudden so yeah I mean you
know there are other words to their
lyrics but I'll take seven soul it's
cool how about guy original legends are
me oh geez oh geez yeah I really knew
just oh gee you never called me Garfield
- oh no that's Uncle Sam right Uncle Sam
did a song once I don't ever want to see
you remember Uncle Sam or when a yeah I
don't ever want to see I think he was a
one hip guy but that one song had a
little bit of momentum a jagged-edged
just it's it's so light you know they
just married they walked out of heaven
his number one on my list how about as
yet rated let me tell you one time we
lived in a bus for 30 days we went ten
thousand miles an hour body or Paul and
scarcely Gus sank as yet on the bus and
after he was done performing
he was still an editor with us nobody
China we thought someone was gonna sign
it we got some but but it didn't last a
long time it was a three minute career
examity yeah as yet the right song about
what yeah very good song shaadi mood
mood Maya sensuous citrus Lee polished
vegetarian vegan vegan television Kevin
Campbell
oh man a young young talent you know
phenom phenomenal kids what writer
extraordinaire Wow concert if you go to
Keith's West Show you will be there for
our in every single song for a whole
hour would be stuff that you didn't
realize he wrote and they all hit like
Oh number one it's like just a whole
night another person like that is my man
um the ilio ssin you're the ocean here
yes yes oh yeah keep sweating you know
what guess what was something else I
remember when he came up
how about Whitney Houston well gentlemen
this has been a blast talkin to you man
I really enjoyed it what can people find
you if somebody wants to find you and
message you where should we send them to
is an Instagram Twitter or website the
channel what can people find you
it's um shower glyph fix on Instagram
and Facebook
whoops wish I knew me like personally if
you want to just come save yourself the
Garfield bright experiences experience
on [ __ ] in shine 90s Darnell I'm gonna
put all of those links below and for
some of you that are watching this that
maybe some of these songs will re
reminded I'm gonna put the links to
iTunes as well for you to go pick them
up download the entire album because if
you just go get all the best it's not
like you got one song
you got several songs to go through a
fellas once again this was a blast for
me more than anything else this way I
appreciate you guys have so much love
for you guys for what you did because
you in my mind some of my greatest
memories in my life had your song
playing in a background and I appreciate
you guys for taking the time for being
against on vitamin man really but thank
you man how about this show all it's on
to and content that you do and the way
you handle yourself and is Dulli and I
appreciate you thanks thank you guys
thank you really
Oh bye so this is normal passion
interview if you follow me on Instagram
or Twitter I'm always talking about my
favorite R&B songs bands and we always
talk about if I ever fall in love again
so if you enjoyed the interview I want
to hear your thoughts comment below and
I got two other interviews I want you to
watch that similar to this one is with
Milli Vanilli do you remember those guys
their whole story if you've not seen
that one click over here and if you've
not seen my sit-down with vanilla ice
telling his story of how he went from
being a regular guy breakdancing to into
a phenomenon to a real estate guy click
here as well and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]
you